This one is particularly complicated.
So because with piaget,
you enter a whole new domain of,
of axiomatic thinking that's the right
way to think about it.
See,
each of these people that we're
discussing,
each of these theories comes out the
construction of the world from a
different perspective.
And it's really fundamentally different.
It's different way deep down at the
level of fundamental assumptions.
And so piaget is who's,
uh,
who's probably the world's most famous
developmental psychologist,
but although he didn't consider himself
a developmental psychologist,
he considered himself a genetic
epistemologist.
And what that meant was that he was
interested in pissed homology,
which is how knowledge structures work
and genetic means formulation of.
And so he was interested in how children
formulate their knowledge structures in
the world.
And uh,
he was a constructivist because he
believed that human beings construct
the,
they don't only construct the
representations of the world and it's
deeper than that.
It's more like the construct the world
itself.
Now,
it depends to some degree on what you
think of as the world.
And of course that's,
so there's a reality definition issue
that's nested at the bottom of this and
it's very complex one.
And so I'm going to have to walk you
through it piece by piece.
Now,
piaget was a genius.
He was,
he wrote a paper I believe on molluscs
when he was 10 and had it published in a
scientific journal.
And he was offered the curatorship of a
museum as a consequence of that.
And his parents had to write the museum
directors and tell them that he couldn't
curate the museum because he was only
10.
And so that gives you some idea about
piaget and he's published many,
many,
many books and many of them haven't been
translated into English yet.
And so he was quite the,
he was quite the,
you know,
large intelligence creature and he
studied all sorts of things.
Uh,
so I'm going to tell you a little bit
about constructivism.
We're going to start you with a quote
from Piaget and to its,
he's done some books,
some of his books I found quite
straightforward and some of them very
difficult.
And I think it's often because of the
quality of the translation.
This happens to be a relatively
difficult section.
I don't think it's translated that well,
but whatever.
We're going to go through it.
I'll explain it to you a little bit.
So Piaget said the common postulate
that's assumption of various traditional
epistemologies,
theories of valid knowledge is that
knowledge itself is a fact and not a
process.
And then if our various forms of
knowledge are always incomplete and our
various sciences still imperfect,
that which is acquired is still acquired
and can therefore be studied statically,
hence the absolute position of the
problems.
What is knowledge or how are the various
types of knowledge possible under the
converging influence of a series of
factors?
We're tending more and more today to
regard knowledge as a process more than
a state,
any being or object that science is to
hold fast dissolves.
Once again in the current of
development,
it is the last analysis of this
development and of it alone that we have
the right to state it is a fact.
What we can and should then seek is the
law of this process.
Quotes.
We are well aware on the other hand of
the fine book by Kuhn on scientific
revolutions.
Now there is an awful lot of information
in that paragraph,
so we'll unpack it a little bit before
we go on.
Now,
one way of looking at science is that
it's a collection of fact,
right?
That's,
that's what piaget is stating to begin
with.
And that was that we assume that the
facts that science has gathered are
facts and static,
but if you observe them across time,
what you find is that scientific facts
tend to shift and transform because
scientific theories that are applicable
in one century,
let's say,
turn out to be less applicable than the
next.
Now there's been a lot of argument and
discussion about this,
um,
because the fact that facts change seems
to indicate that they're not so self
evidently fact and there are people and
perhaps coon would be among them who
believed that science consisted of the
juxtaposition of paradigms.
So those are sets of axioms within which
something operates and the paradigms he
considered them often incommensurate you
couldn't move from one to another
because the axioms were different.
There was no necessarily no what,
what might you say?
There was no necessary means of
communication between them but,
and,
and Piaget knew of Thomas Kuhn's work.
That's the scientist structure of
scientific revolutions,
which was published in 1962 it's a
classic text in the philosophy of
science.
And,
and what piaget assumed more was more
like a,
I would say more like a classic view of
science where,
so for example,
when Newton came up with Newtonian
physics,
there was a set of propositions upon
which Newtonian physics was based.
And then when Einstein transformed those
propositions,
what happened was that Newtonian physics
became a subset of Einsteinian physics.
And so the way that piaget looked at the
development of factual ideas,
at least in part,
was that you'd come up with a set of
ideas that were facts and then that
would be superseded by a different
theory within that,
within which that original theory would
be nested.
And so that what happens that each
theory in some sense,
although it transforms,
it becomes more complete as the
scientific progression continues.
Now,
Kuhn didn't precisely believe that
although exactly what Kuhn meant by a
paradigm shift,
because Kuhn originated that term isn't
clear,
but he didn't seem to actually believe
that science had this capacity to
present a series of facts and then alter
the underlying presuppositions and then
to nest that within a broader series of
facts.
Like you would assume if you were
thinking about the relationship between
Newton and Einstein.
So newtonian physics is a subset of
Einsteinian physics.
So now that's kind of how Piaget thought
about how human beings develop
knowledge.
He believed that we came up with,
well,
let's say you want it to chop down a
tree.
That might be a good example.
I mean,
you could use a a dull ax made of bronze
and it's like,
well that would chop down the tree.
It'd be a lot of work.
They'll,
and then maybe you replace that with a
sharp steel ax that's designed like a
wedge so that you can really hack down a
tree with it.
Or maybe you replace it with a saw.
And so the,
it's not like the bronze ax could chop
down the tree,
but the steel ax can do a better job in
this saw can do even a better job.
And so the way that Piaget thought about
the transformation of human knowledge
structures from,
from infancy onward essentially was that
infants would produce a representation
of the world that was sort of low
resolution but quite tool like it would
work in the world.
But then as they progressed,
the nature of those tools would become
refined and sometimes transformed
completely.
So some,
sometimes you imagine that a child would
use in a sense a low resolution picture
of something and then they would
increase its resolution as they filled
in the details.
That would be a simulation.
That's the Piagetian notion of
assimilation.
You're using the same basic theory but
filling in the details and then now and
then you'd have to switch to another
picture entirely.
And that would be more like
accommodation.
That's where you'd have to transform
your internal structures completely in
order to properly represent an act
within the world.
And so that's the basic difference
between accommodation and assimilation.
So assimilation is like micro
alterations in accommodation is
transformation of the knowledge
structure itself.
And so that's part of,
so what Kuhn pointed out was that
there'd be a set of facts and then
there'd be an anomaly arise of some
sorts of like at the end of the 19th
century,
the only remaining and normally was at
least one of the remaining anomalies was
that,
um,
no matter which direction you shine a
light beam in and no matter how fast the
platform on which you're standing is
moving,
the light beam has exactly the same
velocity,
which seems impossible.
So you know,
if the earth is moving this way around
the sun and you shine a light off the
earth,
you'd expect the speed of light to be
the speed of light plus the speed of the
earth.
And then if you shown it the other way,
than you'd expect the speed of light to
be the speed of light minus the earth
speed.
But that isn't what happens no matter
how fast the platform on which the
person shining,
the lightest standing,
the speed of light is always the same
two every observer.
So,
and people kind of thought of that is,
that wasn't the only anomaly,
but that was one of them thought of that
is the only anomaly left in physics at
the end of the 19th century and it
turned out that was a bad one.
How long?
There was some other ones as well,
like the fact that light tends to behave
as a wave and a particle more or less at
the same time,
which doesn't seem possible.
So there's a couple of things left over
in Newtonian physics that Newtonian
physics couldn't explain,
but by the end of the 19th century there
were famous scientists saying,
yeah,
well we got this all wrapped up.
There's really nothing left to discover.
And then along came quantum mechanics
and Einsteinian relativity and bang,
the whole world was like really
different.
And quantum mechanics is much more
comprehensive theory of the world then
Newtonian physics,
all of the electronics you use wouldn't
work if quantum physics wasn't correct.
Roughly speaking.
And so that little tiny anomaly blew
into something that knocked the slats
out underneath from underneath the
entire axiomatic structure of Newtonian
physics.
It showed it was wrong at its
fundamental level,
even though it turned out to be a
subset,
a correct subset of something that was
much broader.
And so you can kind of think of that as
that's what kids are doing.
As they progress,
they develop a theory that accounts for
a certain set of,
you could say facts,
but it,
this is not a place it gets tricky.
And then they modify those and make them
more and more refined.
But now and then they have to undergo
quite a transformation,
not be a stage transition in piaget.
Adyen thought that that's the stage
transition idea and that would be a,
in some sense to Kuhnian scientific
revolution.
Now what Piaget is trying to state here
is that,
um,
because there's this weird problem with
facts,
which is that they tend to transform
across time.
You know,
like if you go take a biology course
right now in 20 years,
pretty much everything you read,
you learned are very much of what you
learned will turn out to have been
wrong.
And that's kind of weird because it
isn't wrong right now and you'd think,
well,
how can it be wrong in 20 years?
And that that's a really complicated
problem.
And in order to solve that,
you kind of have to think about facts
like tools instead of them as,
as thinking about them as our objective,
independent realities.
Because a bad tool can still work as a
tool,
whereas a bad fact just kills your stone
dead.
And so payers,
anyways,
in any case,
that seems to be a completely
unnecessary phenomena.
Okay.
Oh God,
yeah.
There's no,
no reason for that.
That's just sheer spite as far as I can
tell.
Okay,
so,
so here's one of Piaget's propositions
and,
and it is that because facts flux in
some sense across time,
you're looking for something that
doesn't change across time to call it a
real fact.
And so what Piaget is trying to point
out in this,
let's call it introductory paragraph,
is that the one thing that doesn't
change is the manner in which people
generate facts rather than the facts
themselves.
So the ultimate fact is a fact about the
way people generate fact.
All right?
And so piaget's theory and part is a,
is a theory about how knowledge is
acquired and transformed.
And so it's not that not,
it's not a study of the knowledge
itself,
it's a study of the process by which the
knowledge is generated.
And he believed that that process was
unchanging,
at least with regards to human beings.
And so you could think of the Piagetian
genetic epistemological mystery as
being,
how is it that people form and transform
of the world.
And one of his conclusions about that is
that there's a standard process.
And then the reason that I'm telling you
about piaget right now is because as far
as I can tell,
the standard [inaudible] description of
the manner in which knowledge is
acquired and transformed is the same
thing that's represented in the
mythology of the show.
Monic transformation,
which is that there's a state of being
and then it's disrupted,
disrupted by something chaotic and
there's a disintegration period.
And that's the space between the stage
transitions for,
for children in which time they're often
upset because their little theory about
the world isn't learning isn't working
anymore.
And then in that chaotic period,
they adjust themselves to new anomalies
and anomalies are what occur when you
act in the world and what you want to
happen doesn't happen,
right?
Because that means there's something
wrong with your knowledge structure.
If you act and then something happens,
you don't want to happen.
Something's wrong with the way you're
representing the world.
Or You could say something's wrong with
the world,
but good luck with that.
Although,
you know,
people can modify the world as well as
modifying their belief structures and
people do that a lot.
But so this,
the PPF git and stage transition as far
as I can tell,
is a micro case of the broader idea of
the existence of an orderly state.
It's dissolution into a chaotic state
because something unexpected has
occurred.
And then it's re transformation into a
more integrated state.
Now Piaget would say,
well,
the initial state and the chaotic state
and the final state aren't the ultimate
realities.
The ultimate reality is the process of
moving through those stages.
And that's how people acquire knowledge.
And that's,
you could say that's the central element
of human beings.
And I would say that's a,
that's another re representation of the
hero myth that because the hero is the
person who notes anomaly,
note something that's changed.
It's outside of explored territory in
counters.
It defeats it,
let's say,
or get something of value from it and
then recasts it into the world,
shares it with the community,
restructures the world.
And so that's the central story.
It's,
it's not the central story of human
beings,
but it's,
it's close enough for our purposes at
the moment.
So,
okay,
so that's what piaget is about.
How to human beings encounter the world
and,
and what happens when they do that?
Now the thing about the world for piaget
is it's also a complicated place.
It's not exactly the set of,
it's not the set of all objective facts
that remain to be discovered because
piaget is a constructivist and he's more
of a pragmatist than he is.
Precisely a scientific realist.
And so that's a complicated thing.
Very,
very complicated thing.
I don't know if any of you,
and maybe this is completely irrelevant,
I don't know if any of you listened to
my argument with Sam Harris,
but Sam Harris is a scientific realist
and I was trying to make at least in
part a p is Yeti and point,
but he was having none of that,
that's for sure.
But,
um,
but piaget makes the point and so,
you know,
I'm going to let him speak in some sense
as we proceed through this and,
and uh,
well you'll see why he does what he
does.
So if all knowledge is always in a state
of development and proceeding from one
state
to a more complete and efficient one,
so that,
that implies a hierarchy of states,
right,
that you move from one knowledge
structure to the next one,
which includes the previous one and is
better.
And it's better because it covers more
territory.
That's how you know it's better.
It does the same thing.
The old tool does plus some additional
things.
So it's a definition of better,
it's a good thing to have a definition
of better and worse if all knowledge is
always in a state of development and
consists in proceeding from one state to
a more complete deficient one.
Evidently it is a question of knowing
this development and analyzing it with
the greatest possible accuracy,
which is something I happen to agree
with.
But that's partly because I read Piaget
and,
and I think I understand what he meant
and he's,
he's quite the thinker and so I'm going
to see if I can pull you in a little bit
about this because it's,
it's,
well,
it's exceedingly complex.
You know,
and most of the time when people talk
about piaget,
they just talk about his surface
experiments.
They don't talk about what he was
actually up to.
And what he was up to was while he was
trying to figure out how people
represent the world and learned.
And that's not only,
it's not only that,
you know,
this is another thing people don't know
about piaget,
is that he was trying to reconcile the
chasm between science and values.
That's what drove him through his entire
intellectual life.
He was attempting to bridge the gap
between science and religion.
That's another way of thinking about it.
And that was explicit.
He knew that that's why he did
everything he did.
And so the thing that's so cool about
piaget,
I think is that he actually started to
provide what you might think about as a
rational basis for morality.
It's not exactly rational.
That's the thing because it's rational,
rational belief,
like scientific realism has a certain
set of presuppositions at its core and
piaget doesn't use those presuppositions
to solve the problem.
The problem is so deep,
the the gap between what is and what
ought to be.
That's the David Hume's problem.
You can't derive an ought from an is
just because you know a bunch of things
doesn't give you an unerring guide to
know what to do about those things.
There's a gap there.
And Harris and people like him say that
gap is illusory.
But most philosophers,
including David Hume,
including piaget,
these are heavy duty people,
including heidegger would,
would disagree with that.
They don't believe that,
that,
that that gap is nonexistent.
And,
and,
and Harris believes that you can nest
values within science.
And,
and that's the proposition that he
continually puts forward,
like most of the so called new atheists.
But it's a hell of a lot more difficult
to do than you think that's for sure.
And so,
anyway,
so how is Piaget proporting to manage
this?
Well,
one thing he does is he,
for piaget,
it's really important that you have a
body.
And that's one of the things that's very
cool about his thinking.
So you could think about him as an early
exponent of embodied cognition.
It's like he's not exactly a Cartesian,
a follower of descartes.
He doesn't really believe that you have
a spirit or say a rational mind that is
in some sense,
separate from your body,
which has an implicit presupposition of
a lot of,
uh,
philosophical claims.
Piaget really sticks you in your body.
And the other thing that Piaget claims
is that your abstract knowledge is
actually determined by the structure of
your body and that it unfolds from your
body up into abstraction.
And that's what happens as infants
transform into adults.
First of all,
almost all their knowledge is embodied.
And what that means is that it's not.
Look,
there's a couple of different kinds of
memory like the most,
the most
fundamental distinction you might think
of is between procedural representation,
procedural memory,
and and representational memory.
So when you remember your past,
that little movie that runs in your
head,
or maybe the facts that you can recite
about your past,
that's episodic memory,
that's representational,
but procedural memories,
different procedural memories,
how you walk,
you don't know how you walk.
That's how you ride a bike.
It's how you play the piano.
It's how you type.
So it's,
it's automatic,
right?
It's built into your nervous system.
It's built into the nerves that
innervate your musculature and they're
completely separate memory systems.
Now one can represent the other,
which is interesting.
The representational system can
represent the output of the body,
which is basically what you happen.
What happens when someone tells a story,
even when you tell a story about your
own life.
But the contents of procedural memory,
uh,
proceed the contents of representational
memory and they're shaped in different
ways.
So for example,
part of the wisdom that's encoded in
your body is there because of things
you've practiced.
But it's also there because you've
practiced things in his social
environment.
And so while you practice those things,
the effect of the social environment
shaped the way you learned it.
And that's encoded right in your
neurons.
It's not representational,
it's encoded in the way you do things.
It's encoded in the way you smile when
you look at someone or frown or when you
do that.
And that's all implicit.
It's not under your conscious control.
It's not even in that system.
And so piaget figured this out and so
one of the things he said was that you
start as an infant by building your
procedural memory,
not your representational memory.
That's partly perhaps why you can't
remember your infancy.
You don't actually don't have that kind
of representational memory there.
What you do is you act,
you learn to act,
you build your body so that it can move.
And you do that partly by experimenting
with your own body.
But you also do that by experimenting
with your body in a context that's
shaped from the beginning by the
presence of other people.
So for example,
you know a child learns how to
breastfeed.
It's mouth is pretty wired up right at
birth.
Hey,
and the rest of its body isn't wired up
very much at all,
but its mouth is and you might think,
well that's just a reflex that piaget
would agree with that it's a builtin is
something built in that that a baby can
do right at birth.
But even in the act of breastfeeding,
the baby has to learn how to modify that
reflex so that it gets along with its
mother.
So even at the very beginning with the
most,
you might think the most primordial
acts,
there's a sociological and influence and
there's a mutual dynamic going on that's
really,
really important.
It's really important.
And so in some sense for piaget,
the structure of society is implicitly
built into the structure of the
procedural memory system.
And so one of the things you might think
about that,
and Piaget makes much of this because he
looks at the relationship between play
and dreams and imitation.
So he's kind of a quasi psychoanalyst.
One of the things that means is that
coded in your behavior,
coded in your behavior
is,
is this is the social structure in which
you emerged.
And it's coded in a way that you don't
actually understand.
You just know how to act and then you
can figure out how you're acting and you
can extract out of that some of the
social rules.
But you don't,
you don't,
that doesn't mean that you know the
rules.
It meant that the rules were built into
you.
Here's the way of thinking about it.
Like a wolf pack,
Wolfpack knows how to operate together,
knows how to hunt,
right?
And each wolf knows where every other
wolf is in the dominance hierarchy,
but they don't know.
They know that they don't have rules,
right?
They don't have a code.
They don't have laws.
What they have is behavioral
regularities,
patterned behavioral regularities.
And those are like a morality.
They're very,
very,
in fact,
that's exactly what they are.
A dominance hierarchy of animals that
aren't representational,
you know,
that don't have language.
At least they don't have language.
The dominance hierarchy is a kind of
morality.
It's a way of,
it's a way of setting up individual
behavior within a social context to
maximize cooperation and minimize
competition and so on.
And so piaget would say that,
you know,
the origin of [inaudible] and Frans de
Waal,
who's a great primatologist by the way,
Frenz F,
d,W ,
a,
l,
he's written a lot of books about the
emergence of morality and chimpanzees in
particular.
And you know,
he follows the same line of logic.
It's that the morality emerges out of
the interaction between the chimpanzees
and it's bounded by the necessity that
the actions take certain forms.
So for example,
if the chimpanzees act in a way that
each of them kills everyone else,
it's like that's the end of it.
It's the end of the game.
So that's not a very functional
morality.
It's,
it doesn't produce survival of the
individuals.
It doesn't produce flourishing of the
Certainly it produces extinction of the
individuals and the death of the group.
So as far as dwell would be concerned
from an evolutionary perspective,
that sort of mode of interacting is a
dead end.
And so one of Piaget's claims implicit
claims is that,
and this is one of the things that's so
brilliant about piaget is that,
um,
the interactions between people,
the social interactions between people
necessarily emerge within a kind of
bounded space.
And this space is the space of the game.
So we're always playing games always.
And a game,
you might think about a game as a
microcosm of the world and a small
child's game is a tiny fraction of a
microcosm of the world.
But then you get up into adult games and
you could think about those maybe as
multiplayer online games.
That's one good representation.
But even more sophisticated things like
being a lawyer,
say or like working at Mcdonald's or any
of those things.
Those are also forms of game and,
and that P and people negotiate the
rules and that game is nested inside
sets of broader games.
And so for Piaget,
the game,
the chill,
the games that children play kind of
transform inexhaustibly and,
and,
and what incrementally into the games
that adults play.
And,
and a game that's playable as an adult
is a functional game.
It's an acceptable game.
And one of Piaget's claims is that not
only do people start playing games
unconsciously in a sense and implicitly,
but then they start to play games more
consciously.
They actually,
they actually represent the games to
some degree,
at least in their actions.
Then they start to learn the explicit
rules of the game,
but only later after they know how to
play it.
And then at the highest stage of moral
development,
they start to realize that not only are
they players of games and followers of a
rules,
but they're also producers of rules.
So it start,
you start out not being able to play a
game at all,
then you can play a game with yourself.
Then you can play a game with a few
other people.
Then you can play rule governed games
with lots of people and then you realize
that you make the rules and you can make
new games.
And that's the highest level of moral
development according to piaget.
It's very,
it's brilliant.
It's,
it's bloody brilliant.
He's the first person that I ever really
encountered who was able to put the
notion of an emergent morality on
something,
you know,
broadly commensurate with the scientific
perspective.
But you have to understand that in order
to do that,
he had to sacrifice a little bit of his
notions of scientific realism.
And that's what basic sigma
constructivist.
And so,
and so we're going back to
constructivism.
So he says at the beginning,
and this is the beginning of the
development of knowledge,
just not unfold itself as a matter of
chance,
but forms of development.
So we said there's not only do knowledge
structures change across time and
they're embedded in the social world,
but the manner in which they change
across time actually has a bit of a
structure.
And so that would be the Piagetian
stages of development.
Just so you know,
now,
people have debated ever since piaget
proposed this,
if,
if those developmental stages are fixed
and necessary,
and if he identified them properly and
even,
and as well,
whether or not they could be sped up,
which he always called the American
problem,
could you speed up these stages of
development?
And there's a lot of argument about
whether those stages exist in the manner
that piaget described are and whether
they're fixed it,
all of that.
But that's still the fundamental
elements of,
is the fundamental element of his
theory.
Um,
so,
and in,
in suits,
the cognitive domain has an absolute
beginning,
which means you were,
you're here now,
but at one point you weren't.
So there was an absolute beginning to,
to you as a phenomena,
it's to be studied at the very stages,
gnawing,
known as formation.
That's his rationalization for being a
genetic epistemologist,
right.
Someone who studies the formation of
knowledge structures across time like an
embryologist,
someone like that,
right,
who developmental embryologist,
the first name of genetic epistemology
is therefore if one can say so to take
psychology seriously and to furnish
verifications to any question which each
epistemology necessarily raises yet
replacing the generally unsatisfying
speculative or implicit psychology with
controllable analysis and so basically
what he's saying there is that you can
guess at his stance like Freud did about
developmental psychology.
Freud kind of projected backwards from
his patients into the dim mist of
childhood and came up with like what
would a hypothetical developmental
sequence and Piaget said,
well,
we're not going to do that.
We're going to go run experiments on
kids,
often individuals,
but sometimes multiple individuals.
We're going to,
we're going to observe exactly what
they're doing.
He watched his kids in their cribs for
example,
unbelievably intently and with great,
he was like an ethos logist which is a
person who studies animal behavior
observationally like Frans to wall.
He was like an ethos adjust of children,
not exactly an experimental
psychologist,
although also an experimental
psychologist and he more or less
established the field of developmental
psychology.
So he said,
well let's empirically analyze how
children learn and then maybe we can
figure out how this knowledge process
unfolds and we don't have to guess about
it.
We can,
we can use controllable analysis.
And so you could say he introduced
scientific methodology even though he
wasn't a scientific realist,
he introduced scientific methodology
into the study of child development,
but more importantly into the study of
how knowledge structures unfold across
time.
So he was a philosopher as well,
but a strange type of philosopher
because he was interested in how
philosophy itself emerges in the mind of
the child.
And so that's what piaget was up to.
And so quite quite remarkable.
And he had credibly wide range of
interests be fitting someone who
probably had an Iq of like 190 I mean he
was seriously smart guy,
like way,
way outside of the normal range.
And so this is the sort of questions he
was trying to answer.
Well,
how do you,
on what you base your judgments because
you make judgments about things better
or worse.
Say,
well,
how,
how do you come up with that ability?
How does that emerge?
And on what basis do you make the
judgments?
Um,
there's a famous ruling on pornography
that I believe the Supreme Court of the
United States laid down and one of the
justices wrote something that's become
infamous or famous depending on how you
look at.
He said,
well,
I can't define pornography,
but I know it when I see it.
And,
and that's,
that's a notion of the incomplete
ability of the representational system
to represent the contents of implicit
perception or the or the procedural
system.
You can know that you know something but
you,
that doesn't mean you can describe why
it doesn't mean you can describe how you
know it and you don't.
How do you focus your eyes?
Like you don't know how you focus your
eyes.
You just focus them,
you know,
how do you smile like this?
Well,
maybe less ugly,
but you know,
you can't describe how you do it.
You can't describe the musculature.
You can represent the output of the act
and you can do it,
but you can't represent it and you're
just stuffed full of skills like that.
Which is another example of the way that
you're way more complicated than your
understanding of you.
You know,
one of the things people often ask is
how can we use the rat has a model of a
person cause like,
you know,
a rats,
not much of a person depending of course
on the person.
But the real answer to that is,
well,
compared to what?
Like compared to your understanding of a
person,
a rat is an excellent model of a person.
So it's not as good a model of a person
as a person is.
But compared to imagination,
let's say it's in comparatively better.
And you know,
that's because we share like,
I dunno what,
98% of our genes or some damn thing with
rats,
it's like,
it's really up.
I think we share 90% of our genes with
yeast for God's sake,
you know?
And so we're a lot more rat lake than
yeast.
Like so.
And I think with chimps it's over 99%
you know,
so it's not a bad model.
Obviously it's not perfect,
but it always depends on what you
compare it to.
You know,
when you hear animal rights activists
say things like,
well,
we can replace that with computer
simulations.
It's like,
no,
we can't because you can't simulate what
you don't know or at least not very
well.
So that's a silly idea.
You know,
even though they have a point,
it's not so great to torture animals to
death and all that.
But what are his norms?
Well,
that's a good question.
Where do norms for behavior come from?
You have norms when they're violated,
it annoys you.
It doesn't mean you know what your norms
are,
but you do kind of get a sense of what
they are when they get violated.
That really upset me.
Well,
what does that mean?
you don't really know.
You might have to think about that for
like six months while you got so upset
about that.
But you can notice that you got upset.
And that means that you do have
expectations and norms,
let's say.
But you don't know where they came from.
Now obviously in part they came from
your intrinsic structure,
but also a,
there are a consequence of your
learning,
but even more importantly,
there are consequence of your learning
in a social environment.
So all of those phenomena which exceed
your comprehension determine the nature
of your norms.
And often you only detect them when
they're violated.
So because why bother paying attention
to something that works?
You just don't.
No one does.
They take it for granted.
It's almost the definition of something
working.
It's like,
you know,
you think I'm driving my car to school
and you think you're in a car,
but you're very naughty in a car.
You're in a thing that gets you from
home to school and you can pretend that
that is so annoying.
You can pretend that.
So you might think,
well,
the thing that's I'm,
I'm in,
is it,
it's kind of a weird example is this is
this object with objective qualities
that you call a car,
but,
but that isn't exactly how you actually
perceive or act towards it.
What happens is,
is that as long as it's doing what it's
supposed to do,
which means that its function is intact,
not what it is,
but it's function,
then you can use a really low resolution
representation of the thing.
The car is just what gets you from point
a to point B,
right?
And so the fact that you don't
understand the damn thing at all,
it's completely invisible to you,
but it isn't.
When it quits,
as soon as it quits,
it becomes a car.
It's like bang car.
Oh my God,
I don't understand this thing at all.
Now what do I do?
Well,
you panic a little bit,
right?
Because,
well,
what do you know about your car?
Nothing.
Nothing at all.
And worse than that,
now the car is become the intersection
between you and whoever's going to fix
your card.
So that introduces a whole bunch of
human elements into it.
Like are they going to figure out what's
wrong with it?
Are they going to rip you off?
Is your car ever going to work again?
Are you going to get to work?
What's going to happen tonight?
So all of a sudden that thing that you
were in that was a car turns into this
massive,
complex,
unbelievably complicated thing.
And that's actually what it is.
Your initial representation of it.
It's like it's really low resolution.
It's like one bit and then bang,
it breaks down and Poof,
complexity,
complexity everywhere.
And that complexity,
that's what the world's made out.
If you remember we talked about William
James in that crazy nitrous oxide
induced pseudo tippy poetry that he was
writing in the 1890s when he was talking
about chaos.
Well that chaos that he was talking
about,
out of which order emerges,
that's the same thing as that complexity
that's hovering in the background.
And children have to operate in a world
that's actually that complex.
But they're not smart enough and neither
are you.
So they build partial representations
that sort of work and the parents
scaffold them.
So the way children manage this,
like children,
they don't know anything but stay.
They're still alive.
So what's up with that?
You know,
part of it is the child is laying out
one of its procedures in the world in
accordance with its understanding and
something goes wrong.
What does the child do?
Cries,
right?
It,
it defaults.
It defaults to this distress cry.
And what happens is the adults move in
with their superior skills and their
enhanced understanding and they mediate
between the partial knowledge of the
child and the actual complex world.
And without the child.
That's why if you take your child to the
mall and just leave,
you know,
it doesn't take very long for them to
get really,
really,
really upset,
you know,
depending on the child,
some of them almost instantaneously,
you know,
one day I was in the Boston airport with
my daughter,
she was about three and three and a half
maybe.
And my son,
he was about two and we were there to
pick someone.
I was just packed.
And so I had them by the hand,
you know,
and uh,
I told my daughter a bunch,
if she ever got separated from me in a
crowd just to sit down immediately
wherever she was or as close there by
it,
I would find her don't move well.
Somehow I got separated from them and I
look behind them and they weren't there.
And I found out later she followed
someone else who looked like me from
behind.
And she,
I found her in about three minutes,
you know,
which is a long time man,
if you're three years old at an airport,
she was sitting there like paralyzed,
you know,
butter is,
her brother was with her and he didn't
care at all.
And the reason he didn't care is because
as far as he was concerned,
she was an adult.
But as far as she was concerned,
she was an abandoned kid in an airport.
You know,
it was very hard on her.
And it's because the,
you know,
she was protected from the complexity by
her primordial representations in my
presence.
But as soon as my presence disappeared,
the complexity came flooding back and
just overwhelmed her.
And that's chaos and uncertainty.
And then she'd cry and the cry says,
help I motive by league,
I'm drowning,
you know,
intervene.
And so that's how kids in part can get
along in the world with their incomplete
knowledge representation.
So always also how you get along in the
world because you're,
it's incomplete beyond belief,
but you got all these other people
around you in the whole damn society
filling in the gaps.
And so you walk around like you're doing
what you're doing,
but you don't.
Yeah,
you just hardly know it all.
You know,
if you can fit into that system,
great,
you've got it on your side and you can
use it to fill the gaps.
That's also partly why people are so
concerned with maintaining their social
identity,
like the real identity.
I'm not talking about some surface
identity,
but you see,
because you have set up a set of
expectations and desires about how you
want the world to unfold,
and you do that within a social context
and as long as your desires and the
actions of the community match,
which means you're at home,
roughly speaking,
as long as they match,
you stay emotionally regulated.
You like that.
That's why you can stay calm in here.
It's like your desires are being played
out by everyone else because one of your
desires is that none of these crazy
primates starts brandishing a knife for
example,
or even twitching or any of that sort of
thing.
You don't want any of that.
And if it starts happening,
it's like you get wary very quickly and
maybe you look and maybe you won't and
maybe you'll freeze.
Maybe you'll get the hell out of there.
Maybe you'll get aggressive,
but that match has to maintain itself
intact.
Or your entire nervous system gets
dysregulated.
And the reason for that is that as soon
as that matches disrupted,
the underlying complexity and chaos of
the world reveals itself.
And so does your inadequacy and then
your body defaults into Predator mode.
And,
and the fact that you don't know
anything and that everything is really
complicated becomes very evident to you
very quickly.
And people hate that.
It's the worst thing that can happen to
them,
the bottom falling out of their world.
And so that happens more when your
fundamental presumptions about things
are are challenged.
And then you have to solve the problem
of what constitutes a fundamental
presupposition.
You know,
how do you know which presupposition is
peripheral in which one central?
And you can tell in part because the
more upset you get about something,
the more central it is that that thing's
about to your entire structure of
belief.
And that's one way of getting into that
unconscious structure of bleed from a
psychoanalytic perspective.
So one of the things that happens to me,
for example,
as a therapist has all be talking to my
clients and they'll be talking about
something difficult and all of a sudden
they'll cry and they often don't know
why.
And so I stopped them right there.
It's like something went through your
mind,
something happened.
And the cry indicates that you've moved
beyond your domain of competence out
into the unknown world all of a sudden
into chaos.
What's that chaos,
what exactly happened?
And people,
you know,
they're usually embarrassed that they
cry,
but often they can remember what flitted
through their mind and it's a
represented,
it's a,
it's some encounter with the chaos
beyond their conceptual systems that
produces that emotional response.
And then we can dig into that.
Find Out,
oh,
that's a trauma.
Especially if it's more than a year and
a half old.
And those can be a various depths and
profundity,
you know,
sometimes they're so bad that the person
just breaks down completely and they
never put themselves together.
You know,
that's when something's just wall up to
you.
It's hit you right at the bottom of your
axiomatic structure,
so to speak,
right at the trunk.
But when you're doing therapy with
people and you watch how they respond to
emotionally,
you look for those tiny eruptions of
negative emotion.
And those are like holes in their
conceptual structure.
And those have to be sewed up by their
man.
You in the process of dialogue,
you figure out,
okay,
there was a bit of unexplored territory
there that manifested itself.
It produced an emotional response in you
that indicates that you've reverted in
some sense to childhood.
That would be the Friday and
interpretation.
Now we have to figure out what it was
that it's in that whole what caused that
tear.
And then we have to go back and
articulate it and analyze it and study
it until we can sew it up and then and
our t and and get to the gist of it to
make it into a adaptive story.
And then you can leave it behind and it
actually produces neurological
transformation as you do that.
The memories in some sense actually
moved their psychophysiological
location.
You could say their location in your
psyche,
but you can also note that the brain
systems that are handling the memories
aren't the same.
So they're much more limbic,
they're way lower and closer to the
emotional centers when it's still raw
trauma.
And by the time it's fully articulated,
it's more represented in an articulated
story,
a causal story.
And that's partly why writing about
emotional events actually helps you
overcome them.
So,
and it's possible that writing about how
it is that you overcome emotional events
in general is actually the best kind of
therapy right now.
How do you solve a particular problem?
But how is it that you orient yourself
in the world so that you solve the class
of the fact that there are problems,
right?
That's,
that's the ultimate story.
And I think that's the hero myth.
And I also think that that's the
knowledge generating process that piaget
is talking about you.
That's because you have,
you're constantly overcoming problems in
the world.
And the problems are that you don't know
enough to get what you want from the
world.
And so you get that mismatch mismatch.
There's,
you've got whole brain systems that are
designed to do nothing but detect that
mismatch,
like crucial central brain structures.
And we'll talk about that a lot when we
get into the,
into the physiology.
So,
all right,
how does,
on what is an individual basis
judgments?
What are his norms?
How are they validated?
How do you know if you're right about
your norms?
What's the interest of such norms for
the philosophy of science in general?
That's a really tough one.
It's like,
well you have norms and expectations as
a human being and because of that they,
they have a determining influence on the
manner in which you conduct science.
So for example,
here's one of the problems with the
street realist view.
So we could be having a discussion and I
could say,
well,
you know that tile is to the right of
that tile.
And then I could say,
well this brick is smaller than that
brick.
And then I could say,
you know,
the roof is white,
really quite white there and it's dark
back there.
And like after about 20 statements like
that,
you're just going to want to slap me.
And the reason for that is that,
well those statements are perfectly
valid representations of fact,
but there's an infinite number of facts
and most of them are irrelevant.
And that's the thing.
That's the thing.
The facts have to be relevant.
Like,
if you come to a lecture and all the
person does is tell you irrelevant
facts,
what happens.
You've been in lots of lectures like
that.
What happens when you start fantasizing
about something that might be more
worthwhile,
you know,
or you go to sleep because your brain is
a lot smarter than you are.
It figures hell if all we're going to
get exposed to here as an infant,
infinite number of irrelevant facts,
we might as well have a nap until
something important happens.
So it's true.
It's exactly how it works.
Now this is going to get big.
Isn't that what happens next?
No.
So,
okay.
and then how does the fact that the
child children think differently?
Um,
effect our presumption of fact itself.
Children live in the world,
they think differently about the world,
but yet they survive.
And so,
well,
I already mentioned a partial solution
to that.
Adults intercede,
you know,
around the edges,
around the borders.
Children do this all the time.
May,
so it's called referencing.
Um,
and they do it two ways.
So,
for example,
if you're in a room with your child,
maybe two way and most runs across the
child will orient to it,
watch it,
track it.
That's pretty much unconscious.
And the mother,
let's say,
we'll do that too.
And then the child looks at the mouse
and it looks at the mother and the
reason is is because the child doesn't
know what the mouse is.
And so then it looks at the mother to
read from the mother's face,
which is a projection screen of
emotions,
how to classify the mouse in terms of
import.
And if the mother is like all calm about
it and it gives the kid a pad,
it's like,
you know,
okay,
whatever,
you know,
not to danger.
That's what the most is first danger,
not danger.
It's way after that that it's a mouth.
You think?
No,
it's the most to begin with.
It's like these things are not so
straight forward.
They are not so straight forward.
So anyways,
if the mother climbs up on the table,
it has a screaming fit,
then the child's already prepared
because of this anomaly to be
emotionally responsive.
The child looks at the mother's face,
it's got terror on it.
The most child thinks small danger,
big danger.
It's like phobia,
phobia,
phobia.
Now all kids that won't happen to cause
some are very emotionally robust,
but if their child's very high in
neuroticism,
trait neuroticism,
the probability that they'll develop a
permanent semipermanent fear of the
mouse is extraordinarily high and that's
what should happen because the mother
tells you what the most is in the face.
Does it say mouse?
It says safety.
Danger and that's the first thing you
want to know about something.
He said safer.
Is it dangerous?
And that's a tricky one.
A because whether something is safe or
dangerous is not exactly no objective
fact.
There's a guy named Jj Gibson who wrote
a book called an ecological approach to
visual perception,
which I would highly recommend and his
claim in that book.
It's a real work of genius I believe is
that when you see,
when you walk towards a cliff,
you don't see a cliff,
you don't see a cliff and infer danger,
what you see as a falling off place and
you infer cliff.
And you can tell that some of you have
vertigo.
You go up on the 26th floor out into a
balcony and it's like you don't want to
go near the edge.
Maybe you feel like you're going to
throw yourself over because people have
that kind of what if,
what if I fell or what if I jumped over?
It's like stay away from that.
It's like that perception of the danger
precedes your perception of the balcony
and the object.
Now you know that's how your brain is
wired.
The danger's first object's second.
So when people with blind sight,
who I've talked about before who think
they're blind,
they can't see,
then they tell you that they can still
detect fearful faces and you could
detect their detection by measuring
their skin conductance.
And so their eyes are mapping right onto
their fear and reflex systems without
any intermediary of objective perception
whatsoever.
So don't be thinking that what you see
in the world is the objective world and
then infer its meaning.
It could easily be exactly backwards.
And it looks like if you look at how the
brain is set up that it is in fact
actually backwards,
or at least parallel,
but,
but the,
but the danger,
not danger.
Perception has to be very,
very,
very fast.
And so it proceeds the more elaborate
cognitive interpretations,
even the perceptions because it actually
takes a while to see something because
it's really complicated to see
something.
And so you can't just wait around to see
the damn thing before you act.
You just not fast enough.
So they say if you're a pro tennis
player,
the time it takes the ball to leave your
opponent's racket to get to you,
it's not long enough for you to plan any
motor act.
So what you're doing is you've got the
moat,
you disinhibit the motor act by looking
at the stance of your opponent and
watching.
And by the time they hit it,
you're already prepared for the response
because you're just not,
it's coming at 120 miles an hour.
It's like it's going 50 feet.
You don't have the reflexes for it.
So your,
your,
your eyes are making your body ready
without in some sense,
without your conscious perception,
you become conscious if you make a
mistake,
right?
In fact,
that's kind of what consciousness is
for.
It's like detect error,
fix,
detect,
error,
fix.
That's consciousness.
It's not planned what you're going to do
next,
although it's not that simple either.
Other problems that Piaget was trying to
address.
While what,
what are numbers?
What does it mean for there to be space?
What do we mean when we,
when we talk about time,
how do we,
how did we come up with that concept?
What does speed mean?
How do we know an object is permanent?
How do we know that an object stays the
same across sets of transformation?
So that's a very classic piaget,
Eddie and problems.
So let's say you give a kid a ball of
clay and then you crush it.
So it's now a cylinder is like,
is that the same thing or is it a
different thing?
And the answer is,
well it's the same thing and it's a
different thing,
but there's something about it that
remained constant across the
transformations.
And so one of the things that piaget is
trying to figure out is what remains
constant across transformations.
Because you might think about that is a
real fact.
Protons are like that,
right?
They remained constant across
transformations and so we assume that
they're pretty damn real and they last
guy to know how long protons last.
It's like,
I don't know what it is.
It's some tens of billions of,
so don't worry,
your protons are going to just sit right
there and behave,
you know?
So they last for a very,
very,
very long time across sets of
transformation so we can regard them as
real.
He was interested in why children play
and why there are patterns in play and
how that's related to dreams.
And he was really interested in the fact
that we imitate other people.
And this is another part of piaget,
staggering genius in my estimation,
because he was one of the early
developmental thinkers who understood
that our capacity for learning was not
so much mediated by language as it was
mediated by our capacity to use our
bodies to represent the bodies of other
people.
And that's mind boggling.
It's a mind boggling idea.
So you know,
you hear a monkey see monkey do,
but it's actually not true.
They're not very good at imitating
octopuses or Octopi.
They can imitate actually.
So if you give an octopus a bottle with
a cork in it and there's a crab in the
cork,
it configure it how to get out the cork
and sneak out the crab.
But if you get an octopus to watch
another octopus do that and learn to do
it faster.
Those things are smart.
And that's partly,
that's because they're all technically
right.
And so they actually have something they
can do something with like our hands.
There's our tentacles.
You know,
an Octopi can operate in the world
because they have tentacles and,
and you know,
you hear about the superhuman
intelligence of things like dolphins and
whales.
It's like,
yeah,
no,
they're basically test tubes.
You know what,
what are they going to do snout appa
city?
It's like,
no,
they're not going to do that.
They can't manipulate the world.
So whatever their intelligence is,
it's way different than ours.
Okay.
Imitation.
So partly what you're doing all the time
is imitating other people.
All of you are imitating each other
right now you can tell because look
around,
you're all doing exactly the same thing.
So it's,
it's mass imitation.
And that's really a huge part of social
structure is that we're constantly
imitating each other.
And so that means that your body and her
body are very much matched
physiologically.
Right now you're in the same state and
you can tell,
cause he basically have same expression
and as long as all you crazy primates,
violent primates have the same
expression on,
you can pretty much be sure that all of
you are thinking and about to do
approximately the same thing.
And so you can keep that match between
your desire slash expectation and
reality happening.
And that's why we have a face.
It's so that other people know what the
hell we're up to.
And that's why you're always watching
people's faces.
Cause you want to see what they're up
to.
And that's why you have whites around
your iris.
Gorilla's don't.
And so that's because I can see exactly
where your eyes are pointing because
they're highlighted by that white.
And I'm unbelievably good at detecting
the precise direction of your gaze.
And so if you stand on the corner and
look up at buildings,
other people will stand beside you and
look up cause they think well that guy
would be standing there pointing his
eyes into the sky unless there is
something of interest to a primate like
me.
And so this classic social psychology
experiment,
you'll get people gathered round trying
to figure out what the hell it is that
you're pointing your eyes at.
Right?
Cause that indicates intense interest
interest in something valuable that I
might be able to share or partake in if
I can figure out what it is that you're
up to.
And so all your ancestors who didn't
have nicely defined eyes,
they all got killed or they didn't mate.
And that's why you have these beautiful
white eyes with this like colorful iris
in the middle.
It's so that people can tell what the
hell you're up to and they're more
likely to cooperate with you,
more likely to mate with you and less
likely to kill you,
which is probably a good thing.
All things considered.
And so,
you know,
if you look at the same thing that
someone else is looking at,
your imitating them.
And one of the things that's interesting
is that if you're looking at the same
thing that someone else is looking at
and you inhabit the same value
structure,
then your emotional responses are going
to be very much akin to one another.
And you can tell that when you go to a
movie and you watch the hero and you
embody the hero while you're doing so,
and the emotions that you produce inside
of you by imitating the hero on the
screen enable you to figure out what the
hero is going through.
And you can learn from that.
And so that's a very complex form of
imitation.
And we do that when we tell stories or
we watch stories.
And those stories are really complicated
because as we already outlined,
there not just factual representations
of someone's action during a day there
representations of the important things
that the person did,
the meaningful things.
And so when you go see a movie,
all you're doing is watching meaningful
things.
If the movie's any good.
And you know that because well,
if the movie isn't meaningful,
well then you leave your board,
right?
And the fact that it's meaningful is
what keeps you in the seat.
And you don't necessarily know why.
In fact,
you often have no idea why it's
meaningful.
It's like watching Pinocchio rescue his
father from a whale.
It's like,
what the hell?
You know,
how,
why is that meaningful?
While you don't know.
But it is.
So moral concerns,
while we already talked about Piaget's
concern about morality,
oh boy,
this really not good.
Okay,
here's a proposition.
Constructivist proposition.
Knowledge does not begin in the eye by
by which he means they're kind of two
ways of looking at the world.
There's more,
but we'll start with that.
One is,
is that all of your knowledge comes from
outside sense data.
Okay.
And the,
um,
that's kind of a behavior is claiming
before that it's a,
it's an empiricist claim.
And then the other idea is no,
that can't be right because you have
internal structures that enable you to
look at the world and interpreted and
so,
and in some of those might be implicit
axiomatic,
like the fact that you have two eyes and
you look at the outward into the world
and that you can hear and that you can
touch.
It's like the fact of those senses isn't
dependent on the empirical reality for
those senses to manifest themselves.
They're already built into you.
And people like Khan,
for example,
made the proposition that we had a
priori knowledge structures and that we
use them to interpret the world.
And so it's different than him.
It's different than empiricism.
And so what piaget is saying,
well it's neither of those are,
right,
exactly.
It's not like you will learn everything
from the world through your senses.
And it's not as if you project
everything onto the world as
interpretation.
It's something in between and it's a
dynamic,
it's a dynamic.
And so,
and it's like bootstrapping.
That's the right way to think about it.
You know,
when you're coding computer boots up,
that means bootstrapping,
it's off.
And then a bunch of simple processes
occur.
And then out of those simple processes,
some more complex processes emerge.
And then out of those,
some more complex processes emerge and
all of a sudden your computer is there.
Well that's kind of what Piaget thinks
happens to you.
You bootstrap yourself.
And so you have got a couple of reflexes
to begin with.
Like the sucking reflex for example.
And you've got some proclivities.
Like maybe you can sort of flip your
hand or,
or you develop that and you have
reflexes.
So,
you know,
if you blow on a baby for example,
the PV will go like this.
It's built into it.
It's like an,
it's a,
it's a startle reflex essentially.
So that startle reflex is there right
from the,
again,
it's a whole body reflex.
And,
uh,
you know,
if you stroke the bottom of their feet,
their fetal sort of curl up and if you
put your finger in their hands,
even a newborn,
if you put your finger in their hands,
you can lift them right up.
And it's sort of well clinging ape
thing,
you know,
because chimpanzee infants cling to
their mother for like five years.
And so that reflex is still there.
So the kid comes into the world born
with these simplistic low resolution
procedures that enable it to get a
foothold on the world.
And then out of that,
the child emerges.
And that's so the constructivist idea is
that,
well it isn't like you have your heads
full of fully developed axiomatic
structures and it isn't that you get all
your knowledge from the world,
it's that you have a bit of structure
there to begin with.
That gives you a toll hold on the world.
And then you act in the world and as you
act,
you generate information and out of that
information you make the structures
inside of you and you make the world.
That's a constructivist idea is that you
take whatever's there,
this tremendous complexity and you
sorted into you and the world.
And so,
and so that,
that goes back to that William James
idea about that initial chaos.
And it's a hard conflict.
It's a hard,
hard concept to grasp because that isn't
really how we think.
You know,
we think that there's an objective world
and there's this objective world and
that the objective world is just there
and this objective world is maybe a
subset of that.
But that is not the Piagetian
presupposition.
It's not a presupposition of
phenomenologist in general who will talk
about later.
But,
so here's one example of,
of how to think about this in a sense.
It's like,
you know,
you think as Piaget said,
you kind of think that your
representations of the world are fixed.
So we'll go back to the urine,
a longterm relationship and the person
betrays you scenario,
right?
So you've been with this person 10
years.
You assume fidelity and faithfulness and
honesty and all of that.
You,
you,
uh,
we've a shared narrative.
You both had habitat,
it structures your existence and
regulates your motion.
Then you find out that the person has
not only betrayed you once,
but multiple times.
It's like,
okay,
what you thought isn't what happened,
but here's the weird thing you see
because you interpreted the world
obviously within the confines of that
relationship and you had an,
you know,
obviously you had an interpretation,
but there was also a world that's the
world you thought you lived in.
It's like those were facts.
Well all of a sudden those aren't facts.
They're not at all facts.
And so what happens that's that descent
into the underworld.
It's like all of a sudden what happens
is that past that you thought was fixed
now becomes this weird mixture of
fantasy because you're wondering,
well what,
what,
what?
What is it that happened then?
And you're going to run through all
sorts of fantasies.
Some of them are going to be really
dark,
you know,
really dark about what happened in the
state of the world and all that.
And those are unconscious fantasies.
And that's mingled inextricably with the
world,
right?
Because you don't know the facts
anymore,
which kind of suggests that maybe you
never did know them.
And that's pretty strange thing because
you know you're operating as if you've
got this factual representation of the
world,
but it can be appended like that.
And so that makes you think,
well what about these facts?
Like are kind of,
they're kind of hard to get a handle on.
You know,
and you see this a lot in courtroom,
in courtrooms situations because of
course what the court decides is what
happened.
And the answer is we don't exactly know
because you could keep making the
context of interpretation wider and
wider.
So you know,
maybe you bring your partner to court
because they've betrayed you,
let's say.
And you're trying to get a divorce
settlement predicated on that.
But then they tell a bunch of stories
about how you were just as miserable as
you could possibly be and that anybody
with any sense would've betrayed you and
never told you about it because you
know,
that's just what a normal,
sensible person would do.
And so then the question is,
well,
where you actually be trade?
And if you were,
well,
who was it that betrayed you?
Was it your partner?
Was it you or was it your bloody mother
or your father who taught you to act
that way or who didn't teach you?
It's like,
it's a hell of a thing.
Cause you can just keep altering the
interpretive context and within it,
the facts shift around and then you
might say,
well,
they're not facts.
It's like,
yeah,
you can say that,
but it's,
it's more complicated than that by a
large margin.
Anyways.
So Piaget's notion is essentially that,
well this is how I interpreted this is
sort of,
this is my thinking in some sense,
but I'm offering it to you as a scheme
for helping you understand piaget.
It's like Jerome Bruner,
famous,
famous cognitive psychologist,
said,
we seem to have no other way of
describing live time set except in the
form of a narrative and a narrative.
As far as I could tell,
I think this is the same thing as one of
Piaget's knowledge representations as
far as I can tell,
there's a representation of you and
there's a representation of the future
and there's behaviors that you use to
transform one into the other.
And so when piaget talks about,
so this is kind of where the mind meets
the body,
that that's how it looks to me.
It's like you have a conception of you
and you have something you're aiming at,
you want to have happen.
Those are both representations,
but when you act in the world,
those aren't representations anymore.
Those are actually actions.
And so mine transforms into body when
you act out your notion.
And that's,
that's sort of how the mind is linked to
the body as far as I can tell.
And so what Piaget says is that the
behaviors are built before the
representation.
And so we're going to take a look at
that.
So here's,
here's Piaget's notion of assimilation
and accommodation,
whereas other animals cannot alter
themselves except by changing their
species.
That's through Darwinian means,
right?
So what happens is a bear is a kind of
solution to a set of problems and
they're the problems that the bears
environment presents.
And the bear is just a bear.
So it's sort of like bears were 10,000
years ago and the only way the bear can
solve a new problem basically is by
generating new random bears,
which is what it does when it
reproduces.
And hoping that one of those more random
bears is a better fit for whatever
random change might occur in the
environment.
That's the whole Darwinian issue,
right?
You can't predict which way the
environment's going to go.
And so what you do is you take your
structure and you vary it and you throw
those out into the world.
And some animals do that expensively,
so they have infants that they have to
program to that specific environment.
But it takes a lot of investment.
And some creatures do that cheaply,
like mosquitoes.
It's like they don't care for their
kids,
but they have a million of them.
So like who cares if 999,998 die?
There's still twice as many of you as
their work.
So those are two different reproductive
strategies and you could think about all
those mosquito offspring as new mosquito
ideas in embodied form.
And most of them are bad ideas.
And so the environment just wipes them
out.
Or Piaget is point is we do the same
thing with our cognitive structures.
And that's the thing that's so
interesting about people in some sense
that we've internalized the Darwinian
problem.
And so when you think about the future,
what you're doing is generating a
multiplicity of potential environments
and then you're generating a sequence of
avatars of yourself to live in those
fictional futures.
And then you watch what happens as that
avatar lives in each of those,
those fictional futures.
And if the avatar fails,
you don't act that out.
It's bloody brilliant.
It's brilliant.
That's what our brain does.
It's like it hypothesizes potential
futures.
It runs simulations and it kills them.
And that can be really painful,
but it beats the hell out of dying
yourself.
Or maybe sometimes you won't think so
because it really can be painful,
but it's,
it's,
it's something that as far as we know,
only human beings can really do,
right?
We invent possible futures and invent
possible future selves and kill them off
in our imagination.
And that's what you're doing in an
argument.
That's what an argument is.
It's like,
well,
here's an Avatar,
a representational avatar.
You know,
it's based on certain axioms and all
articulate it and you articulate yours
and we'll have them have a fight and
whichever one survives,
we'll accept as true and we'll move
forward and act that out.
And you know,
arguments can be pretty damn intense,
but hypothetically,
they're not as intense as acting out a
stupid idea.
That's the thing,
right?
Better to have some conflict and reach
resolution in an abstract sense than to
embody your stupidity and die.
And so,
you know,
it's sort of a trade off between anxiety
and an annihilation or pain,
whereas other animals cannot alter
themselves,
except by changing their species.
Man can transform himself by
transforming the world and constructor
himself by constructing structures and
the structures.
Arizona,
they're not eternally predestined either
from within or from without.
Also piaget,
you know,
he's,
while he's a constructivist,
he believes that there's something that
your biology brings to the table and,
and,
and sets up the parameters,
let's say within which you can play
games.
But within those parameters there's a
very wide range of games that you could
play.
And so it's not a biological
determinism,
even though it's a biological framing.
And you can think about it like a chess
game.
You know,
let's,
let's assume that the rules of chess or
biologically determined just for the
sake of argument,
you can still play a near infinite
number of chess games.
And so it's the same with you.
You come into the world with a set of
built in axioms that sort of your body
and your nervous system,
but you can play a very large number of
games within that set of frames.
And one of the things that's very
interesting about that,
something that's very mysterious to me
is this is a game that I played before
with students.
So I'm going to play it with you if you
don't mind.
So we're gonna play a game.
You're ready?
Okay.
You move first.
Right?
Exactly.
You don't know what to do.
Right.
And that's,
well,
that's so interesting because I
basically made the presupposition that
you could do anything.
You're completely free.
And what,
what do you do?
You throw up your hands,
it's like you don't know what to do.
I'm so free.
It's like free to do what?
Well,
that's not freedom.
It's just nothing.
But if I said,
well,
look,
what we're going to do instead is when I
move my arm,
right,
you're gonna move your arm.
Right?
So let's do that.
Okay,
so I'm going to go like that and you're
going to good.
And then I'll go like that and then
we'll have little dance.
Yeah.
And so you can play a game like God with
a,
with a kid instantly.
And they like that.
They've got that man.
And so I've got to,
I've got some pictures of that.
I'll show you that in a bit.
But even a newborn baby,
if you stick out your tongue,
they can stick their tongue,
hold back and that you think about that.
That's just absolutely mind boggling
that they can do that and,
and they really can,
they really do seem to be able to do
that right at the moment of birth.
And so you know,
you hear babies have no theory of mind.
It's like ah yeah,
no,
they can imitate.
That's pretty bloody amazing man.
Like you haven't seen robots that can do
that yet.
Although there are robots now that you
can teach by moving their,
their arms,
you move their arms and then they'll do
it.
And so you can actually program them by
moving them and then they'll just repeat
it.
And so they're getting damn close to
imitation.
They're really getting close and then
look the hell out man,
because they're going to be imitating
each other as well as us and they're
going to do it so fast.
You just won't be able to believe it.
So that's coming.
The organism adapts itself by third
materially constructing new forums to
fit themselves into those of the
universe.
Whereas intelligence extends this
creation by constructing mental
structures which can be applied to those
of the environment.
That's the Darwinian idea that I just
mentioned.
You know,
the guys that are building the
autonomous cars,
like they don't think they're building
autonomous cars.
They know perfectly well what they're
doing.
They're building fleets of mutually
intercommunicating,
autonomous robots.
And each of them you to be able to teach
the other because their nervous system
will be the same.
And when there's 10 million of them,
when one of them learn something,
all 10 million of them will learn it at
the same time.
So they're not going to have to be very
bright before they're very,
very,
very smart.
Cause us,
you know,
we'll learn something you have to
imitate.
It's like God that's hard.
Or I have to explain it to you and you
have to understand it and then you have
to act it out.
We're not connected wirelessly with the
same platform,
but robots.
They are.
And so once those things get a little
bit smart,
they're not going to stop at a little
bit smart for very long.
They're going to be unbelievably smart
like overnight.
So,
and they're imitating the hell out of us
right now too,
because we're teaching them how to
understand us every second of every day.
The net is learning what we're like.
It's watching us,
it's communicating with us,
it's imitating us.
And it's going to know it already knows
in some ways more about us than we know
about ourselves.
You know,
there's lots of reports already of
people getting pregnancy ads or ads for
infants sometimes before they know
they're pregnant,
but often before they've told their
families.
And the way that that happens is the net
is watching what they're looking at and
inferring with its artificial
intelligence.
And so maybe you're pregnant and that's
just tilting you a little bit,
right to interest in things that you
might not otherwise be interested in.
The net tracks that then it tells you
what you're,
what you're after.
It does that by offering an
advertisement,
if it's reading your unconscious mind so
well.
So that's what's happening.
So,
all right,
so what's the motive for development?
Disequilibrium.
That's a Piagetian term.
This is a life is suffering idea.
It's like,
why learn something cause you're wrong.
Who cares.
It makes you suffer.
You care.
So you know,
if you run out a little scheme in the
world,
little action pattern,
you don't get what you want.
If you're,
especially if you're two years old,
you burst into tears and cry.
And why is that?
It's because you don't know what,
you don't know where you are and you
don't know where you're,
what you're doing.
It's like time for some negative
emotion.
It indicates that you're wrong.
And that's terrible in some sense
because it all,
it almost always means that to learn
requires pain.
Now I don't believe that.
Exactly because
people are curious,
you know,
and to go out and be curious and to
learn new things can be very exciting.
And so what it seems to be is that
there's,
there's a rate of learning that's too
fast and that hurts you.
That's what makes you cry.
But if you get the rate just right,
you're just opening up enough novelty so
that you can benefit from the
possibilities that gives you a dopamine
kick.
Fundamentally,
you can benefit from the possibilities
without being overwhelmed by the,
by the unexpected element of it.
And you can tell when that's happening.
And this is one of the coolest things as
far as I'm concerned.
This is an,
I learned this partly from piaget.
It's like,
you know,
in order to withstand suffering,
let's say your life has to have some
meaning.
Okay,
well that that means a bunch of things.
It means that part of the way that you
overcome suffering is by making the
suffering into something meaningful.
And I don't mean that metaphysically,
I mean it technically you've made a
mistake,
it causes you suffering,
you learn something about it.
You don't make that mistake again.
It's real adaptation.
It's not,
it's not defense against death anxiety
or something like that.
It's real adaptation.
But more importantly,
the reality that you learned through
pain is the oldest reality.
We'll say it's,
it's really old.
It's as old as nervous systems.
And so you've adapted so that you've
learned to transform your knowledge
structures in a way that will minimize
your potential exposure to future pain.
Add a rate you can tolerate or maybe
even enjoy,
and so what's happening is you don't
actually like static.
It bores you,
but you don't like being thrown into
chaos.
It's like no little bit of,
that's fine.
What you want is you want to be opening
up your no old structures on the
periphery to transformation,
voluntary transformation.
That's voluntary exploration and letting
those things manifest a little bit of
interest in chaos and so you have a
little bit,
you put a little feeler out there that
you're willing to let die and it comes
apart and you gather a bit of
information,
it comes back together stronger and you
do that all the time.
If you're,
if you're smart and you're looking for
new information foraging for new
information,
and that means you keep taking little
bits of yourself apart and
reconstructing them and over time that
keeps you alive and active.
You know,
part of the reason you're alive is
because you're dying all the time,
right?
All the cells in your body,
like if they don't die,
you get cancer and that that's it.
You're,
you're done.
You're a very,
very tight balance between death and
life at every,
every single level,
including the cognitive level.
And it's not that fun to learn something
because you have to kill something you
already know in order to learn it.
That's another Yeti observation cause
you,
you're always interpreting something
within a structure and if that
interpretation is wrong,
even in a micro way,
you have to kill that structure and it's
a biological structure,
it actually hurts to kill it.
But maybe you can generate something new
in its stead and if you get the dynamic
right,
let the rate right,
then you find that exhilarating,
not painful.
And that's,
and that's well you can tell when you're
doing that.
As far as I can tell,
you can tell when you're doing that
because you're engaged in the world in a
meaningful way and what your nervous
system is doing is signaling to you that
you're not in a static place that's
death.
You're not in a chaotic place.
That's death.
You're balanced between the static and
the chaotic such that the static
structures are transforming at exactly
the right rate to keep you on top of the
environmental transformations.
And so you're surfing,
you know,
in Hawaii,
surfers surfing was sacred.
Well that's why it's like can you tell
someone how to surf?
Well,
you can't because they have to go out
there and dynamically interact with the
wave,
but they can stay on top of the wave and
that's what you have to do and if you're
staying on top of the wave properly,
then it's exhilarating.
And that's the kind of meaning that,
that it rejuvenates you literally.
It makes you able to tolerate the
suffering in life and it's not
metaphysical precisely.
It's because that is what you're doing
at that moment.
You're,
you're overcoming your limitations.
And of course that's what you have to do
in order to,
to know and to learn because you want to
be doing both of those things at the
same time.
That's what you do when you play a game
properly.
Your parents say it doesn't matter
whether you win or lose,
this is a phd,
an observation.
It's how you play the game.
What does that mean?
Well it means that you should play the
game in a manner that increases the
probability that you're going to be
invited to play many games in the
future.
Perfect.
So you master the skills of the game,
but at the same time you master a set of
medis skills,
which is the skills remained constant
across transforming sets of games.
And that's what it means to play fair.
That's a bloody basis of morality as far
as piaget was concerned.
It's so damn smart.
You know,
cause you think all interactions have
this game like quality,
there's sort of bounded and but there
are commonalities across all the games
and you want to extract out the
commonalities and you want to learn to
inhabit the universe that's made out of
the commonalities between games and
that's what it means to be a good
person.
Roughly speaking.
You know,
it varies to some degree from culture to
culture obviously,
because each culture is a game unto
itself.
But there's something that transcends
that.
That's the nature of games across game
contexts.
And you know that,
you know that because you can tell the
difference between a game and and
something that isn't the game instantly.
Everyone knows.
And it's not like there's only one kind
of game.
There's hockey say and there's,
there's a world of warcraft.
I know it's way out of date,
but so am I.
So it's not surprising.
So,
but the fact that those things are very,
very different in,
in many,
many ways.
It doesn't stop you from identifying the
underlying commonalities.
You know,
their games and their,
they're like stories in a sense.
So,
and that's a Piagetian.
That's a Piagetian observation.
Very,
very smart.
So why do you develop?
Well it's because your previous idea
there,
your previous frame,
micro frame,
let's say,
doesn't fit the circumstance.
And so something happens.
It,
you go like this,
what's up?
Well,
the world isn't what you thought and
there's something wrong with your
knowledge structure.
And this is partly what makes piaget a
pragmatist.
You see the pragmatists,
American School of Philosophy,
William James and his followers,
they knew that we had bounded knowledge.
We don't have infinite knowledge.
And so they thought,
well,
that means we can't really be right
about anything because we're definitely
wrong.
And so how is it that you can operate in
the world given that you're always
wrong?
And the answer is
you set up a procedure that has rules
for what constitutes true within the
procedure itself.
So you play a game and at the same time
you set up the rules.
So you might say,
well,
is this joke funny?
And then the answer is,
well,
do people laugh now when I tell the
joke,
do they laugh?
And if the answer's yes,
then it's funny enough you've,
you've,
you've taken a particular definition of
funny,
you've transformed it into a local
phenomena.
And if your behavior matches the
prediction in that local area,
you say,
well that's true enough.
Is it like transcendently funny.
Well maybe you'd have to tell it to 200
different groups of people to figure
that out.
But mostly it's,
it's funny enough so that when I
predicted what would happen when I told
the joke,
that's what happened.
And you don't predict it by the way you
desire it.
It's not the same thing.
Cause prediction has no motivation in
it,
but desire does and we're always
motivated,
always,
always motivated.
So well,
here's a way of thinking about the Ph
Eddie and system.
So two year olds,
they're very
chaotic and they bounced between one
highly motivated emotional state to
another.
And so the first thing that the two year
old has to do is get his or her act
together more or less inside.
And so,
you know,
two year olds still have tantrums and
they still cry a lot and they still run
around like mad being joyful crazily,
which you have to train out of them
right away because it's nothing but
disruptive.
And it's one of the most painful things
about being a parent.
It's like 90% of the time you're going
stop having fun,
stop having fun.
You know,
and then you turn into a teenager and
your parents get what they asked for.
And so,
but because positive emotion is so
impulsive and so chaotic,
it's really hard to manifest itself.
It manifests it within a,
within a predictable environment.
And so you're dampening down your
child's enthusiasm nonstop.
It's but it has to be regulated because
happiness is impulsive and chaotic and
people don't like to think that because
they think,
well,
we should be happy.
It's like Mannix or happy,
but they're maniacs.
That's where the word comes from.
Like they're just,
it's not good.
There are two happy way too happy,
like someone who's way too stoned on
math or on cocaine and I mean that
technically because it's,
they're very similar.
They're very similar biochemical states,
so and and cocaine produces happiness
pretty much in its pure form.
So does meth very rapidly and so it's
just not good.
You know,
you lose judgment.
He happy.
People do not have good judgment.
They're too happy they're here,
they get dopey.
It's like,
you know,
it's like irrational stock market
bubbles.
Oh boy,
it's always going to go up.
It's like,
no,
it's not always going to go up,
but that's what you think when you're
happy.
Anyways,
the two year old has to get all these
motivational systems sort of hammered
into one thing internally.
Now in some sense from the Piagetian
perspective that happens within the
child,
he thinks of the child is egocentric,
but,
and,
and that that development takes place
internally and then it's not until the
child's,
let's say about three that it can learn
to bring it's controlled unity into a
unity with another controlled unity and
make a game that happens around three.
And so what happens is that instead of
the child only pursuing his or her
goals,
although modulated by the social
environment,
the child is able to communicate with
another child and establish a shared
goal.
And that's what happens when they play.
And so obviously you play monopoly.
That's what you're doing.
But when you play Peekaboo,
you doing the same thing.
It's like with your parents,
you're actually playing with object
permanence.
Dad's gone,
Oh look,
dad's here.
Ha Ha,
look,
he's their dad's gone.
Dad's here,
dad's gone.
Dad's here.
The Kid Ben,
you can do that for like three hours.
They'd ever get tired it because every
time you reappear,
it's an,
it's a miracle in you watch babies.
It's so funny.
Like you go like this and they go,
then you pop back out and they,
they're so happy,
they're just overjoyed.
And then you take yourself away and
they're like,
what's going on?
What's going on?
Bang.
You reappear.
They don't have a real memory,
you know,
it's like reality is manifesting itself
in all its freshness moment by moment
and they can't remember it.
There are neurological conditions that
do that.
So sometimes,
and there are people who that this has
happened to.
So to get hippocampal damage and so they
can't move short term information into
longterm storage.
And there's this one guy,
it very interesting case,
he was a concert pianist and he had a
hell of a neurological injury and um,
he could still play the piano,
he couldn't remember ache,
he couldn't,
he had amnesia and he couldn't move
information from short term storage into
long term storage.
So as far as he was concerned,
it was,
it was always like 10 days before he had
his accident.
He never got passed out.
He was stuck in that moment and then,
but he could still play the piano.
And by was so interesting.
You watch him,
there were films of him before he sat
down to play the piano.
He'd have like a seizure and then he
could play the piano procedural memory
that was intact.
And then at the end he kind of have a
little seizure and then he'd go back to
being who he was.
But he had these notebooks and all he
did was write in them over and over.
The same thing.
It's as if,
I've never seen this before.
It's as if I've never seen this before.
So he's in this ecstatic state where
everything was novel and new and pure in
paradise,
but there was no continuity.
And so when his wife would come to visit
him,
he would just be overwhelmed to see her
overwhelmed every time.
And even if she just left the room and
came back in,
it was exactly the same thing.
It's just like the kid.
It's like no object permanence.
And every time the face appears,
it's,
it's a staggering,
and you can see that in the reflexes of
the child.
And that's,
that's without object permanence.
And so that's what piaget was talking
about with regards to object permanence.
It's very,
very cool.
So anyways,
the two year old's a collection of these
sort of random motivations,
more or less gets his or her act
together by about three if they're being
socialized properly.
And that means that the parents are
doing their best to make the child
acceptable to other children.
That's your damn job as a parent,
you have to understand that because if
your child is an acceptable to other
children,
they won't play with your child and then
your child will be lonesome and isolated
and awkward and they will never recover
because if the kid doesn't get that
right between two and four,
it's silver.
They're never going to learn it.
The other kids accelerate forward that
kids left behind and it's not a good
life for that kid.
They don't learn how to play with
others.
And then they're done.
And there's a huge literature on trying
to rectify antisocial children,
say from the age of four on,
it's like,
no you can't.
And you can go ahead and read three,
400 papers on rectification of social
behavior.
And figure it out for yourself.
But I did that for about five years and
it was a while ago,
but I know the literature hasn't
changed,
so you got to get it right between that
period.
You got to get the kid together enough
so they can control themselves well
enough so that they can adopt a mutual
frame of reference with a peer so that
they can start using that to scaffold
their development further and become
more and more sophisticated and social
interactions.
And that's what you're,
you're acting as a proxy for the social
environment.
As a parrot,
that's what you're doing now.
A gentle proxy and informative proxy,
maybe even a merciful proxy,
but a proxy nonetheless,
because they're not going to be around
you forever.
They're going to be out there among
people who don't really care about them.
And if they don't have something to
bring to the table,
at least the ability to cooperate,
they're going to be lonesome and
isolated,
and that's not going to be good.
Well,
here's a,
here's an,
here's an idea.
So as you're moving from what is to what
should be,
you're in this little frame of
reference,
this little game,
this little Piagetian game.
Sometimes you get what you want or
predict,
that's on the left hand side that makes
you happy and it validates your frame.
So if the frame keeps working across
different circumstances,
you get a reward from that.
The reward produces dopaminergic kick
that makes you feel good,
but the dopamine also enhances the
strength of the circuitry that underlies
that particular representation.
That's what reinforcement is.
It's different than reward.
Reward is what you feel,
let's say roughly speaking.
Reinforcement is the effect of the
dopamine bathing the neurological
tissues to make it stronger and grow.
And so if the neurological tissue
underlies a sequence of actions that
produces the desired outcome,
there's a biochemical kick that
strengthens the nervous structures that
were activated just before the good
thing happens.
And so that's how something,
you know that's valuable,
gets instantiated,
and if it fails,
instead you get punished.
Pain,
anxiety,
and that,
that starts to extinguish that
circuitry.
And we don't know how that works
exactly.
We don't know exactly if those circuits
then start to die because they can
degenerate across time or if what
happens is you build other circuits that
inhibit them.
So it's like you've got this knowledge
structure,
it's built into you and once it's there
there's not really much getting rid of
it,
but you can build another one that tells
it to shut up.
Not sort of what happens when you're
addicted to drugs.
So cocaine bathes the tissue that was
active just before you took the cocaine
with dopamine and so that gets stronger
and stronger and stronger and stronger.
And so you're basically building a
cocaine seeking monster in your head and
that's all it wants.
And it has rationalizations and it has
emotions and it has motivations and it's
alive,
but it wants one thing.
And the problem is once you build that
thing,
especially if you nail it a couple of
hundred times with a powerful
dopaminergic agonist like cocaine,
that thing is one vicious monster and
it's alive and it's in there and you
can't get it to go away.
The only thing you can do is build
another structure to shut it up.
But the problem is is that as soon as
you get stressed,
it interferes with that new structure
and the old thing comes popping back up.
Not Good.
I wouldn't recommend it.
And the faster acting.
Okay,
those dopaminergic agonist,
star cocaine is a good example.
But so is math.
The faster they hit you,
which is often why people inject them
instead of starting them.
Say the faster that transformation from
steady state to dopaminergic bath,
the bigger the kick is.
And so you know,
so speed of introduction of the
substance matters,
which is why you drink shots instead of
drinking say wine or beer because
alcohol has very similar,
very similar effects.
So
all right,
so if you get what you want,
well then you feel good.
But not only do you feel good,
but the frame itself is validated.
And if you don't get what you want,
well then not only do you not get what
you want,
but the frame itself starts to come
apart at the seams.
And the question and parties,
how far should the frame come apart?
How deeply should you unlearn something
when you make a mistake.
God,
it's a very,
very,
very hard problem.
And I'll show you a partial solution to
it is a very useful thing.
And this is a Piagetian idea too.
Let's see.
Yeah,
I'm going to go to this for a minute.
So,
so
I'm going to decompose something for
you.
And,
and this is partly to give you an
introduction to the way behaviors to
think,
but it's also to help unpack how the P
is Yeti and notions work.
And so from a Piagetian perspective,
high order abstractions are actually
made of what's common among actions and
perceptions.
So,
and those things are unified in some
sense.
So an abstraction isn't what's common
across sets of objects.
It's more like what's common across sets
of perceptions and actions.
And so it's a hard thing to understand,
but,
but this will help you understand.
Okay.
So let's say you want to be a good
person,
these kind of abstraction.
All right?
And then you think,
well,
what does it mean to be a good person?
It's a box.
It's an empty box.
No,
it's a box.
And it says good person on the outside,
but it's full of things and might even
be full of transforming things.
So,
but you know what it means.
You say good person,
you kind of know when you kind of know.
But you know,
if we started talking about details,
we might start to argue,
but it's like pornography.
You know it when you see it.
Okay,
so what does it mean to be a good
person?
While we could decompose it,
we could say,
well,
if you're one way of being a good person
is to be a good parent.
And you basically say that being a good
parent is a subset of being a good
person,
right?
Because person is bigger than parent and
maybe it'd be to be a good employer and
to be a good sister and to be a good,
you know,
to be,
to be a good,
a good partner,
sort of on the same level of
abstraction.
So you decomposed good person into your
major functional roles,
let's say,
and you're good at all of them,
whatever that means.
Well,
let's say if you're a good parent,
well,
you have to have a good job because
otherwise you starve and soda your
children.
So at least you have to financially
provide in some manner.
That's a subset of being a good parent.
It's not the only subset.
And then to be a good,
to have a good,
be a good parent,
you also have to take care of your
family.
And so you could decompose that into
play with baby or complete meal.
You might say,
well,
if you can take care of family,
you can either order a meal or you can
cook one.
It's like good for you.
And so then you're cooking a meal and
you think,
well,
what do you decompose that into?
Well now you're starting to get to the
micro level.
Say,
because let's say you're making
Broccoli.
So you take the Broccoli out of the
fridge and you put it on the cutting
board.
That's actually action.
That's not abstraction.
It's actually something you're doing
with your body.
So the abstraction grounds itself out in
micro activity,
actual action,
that's the connection between the mind
and the body.
And so you're cutting Broccoli,
right?
But that's not abstraction.
And so if you take apart these higher
order moral abstractions,
what happens is you decompose them into
action perception sequences and they're
embodied.
Now,
Piaget's basic claim is you build the
dam abstractions from the bottom up.
That's his,
that's the fundamental piagetian claim.
It's so the kid comes into the world
with some reflexes and starts building a
body of embodied knowledge out of that
interaction with other people.
And then they start playing games in
that abstracts.
But,
but they moved from the bottom of the
hierarchy,
which is actual micro-actions up to the
top of the abstraction world.
And so it's,
this is how you boost yourself up.
Little bitty stories.
What little bitty stories at the bottom,
cut Broccoli,
you know,
and then cut corn here,
set table,
do dishes,
complete meal,
take care of your family,
be a good parent,
be a good person.
And you know,
one of the propositions that I am
offering you in this class is that to be
a good person,
you're actually not stuck in one of
these.
To be a good person means that you're
the thing that transforms these things
continually.
And so that's what's at the top of the
hierarchy.
And that's basically the hero story,
which is you're in a state of being,
an anomaly occurs,
you allow it to demolish you,
and then you rebuild.
And that's at the highest end of the
moral hierarchy.
And that's also essentially a Piagetian
claim.
So,
so let's think about emotional
regulation because this is a really good
schema for understanding emotional
regulation.
How upset should you get and how do you
calculate it?
Because if you make a mistake,
you wake up in the morning and your side
hurts,
okay,
you,
it's the first symptom of pancreatic
cancer.
You're dead in six months,
a hundred percent chance,
or you know,
you pulled a muscle.
Well,
which is it?
You might say,
well,
the chances of the pancreatic cancer
low,
but they're not zero.
And like infinite times,
any proportion is a very large number.
So you might be thinking,
why don't you just have a screaming fit
anytime ever,
any little thing happens to you,
which is exactly what happens.
By the way,
if you're two years old,
right?
That is what you do.
So,
and it's because you don't know.
You don't know,
like things fell apart.
What does that mean?
Could be anything.
Well that's no good.
Well,
so let's say you're arguing with your,
with your partner,
you know,
and they,
uh,
I dunno if they make a lousy meal or
maybe no meals and you're kind of sick
of it,
you know?
And so you say you're a bad person and
what's the evidence?
Not only are you a bad person,
but you've always been a bad person and
the probability that you're going to
improve in the future,
it looks to me to be zero.
It's like what's the person supposed to
do punch you,
right?
Really,
because there's no room in there for any
discussion.
You're done.
It's like you're horrible
and you don't change and you've always
been horrible and you've never changed.
And you know,
inferring from that into the future,
you're going to stay horrible and you're
not going to change.
Well at any argument can go there
immediately.
It's a really bad idea and it happens
all the time.
And this is why people can't have a
civil discussion.
You know,
they can't say,
MMM,
here's an example.
So you've got your four year old,
you want them to clean up their room,
and so it's full of toys.
Let's say they're three and a half.
You look at it and say,
look,
you know,
clean,
clean this up,
clean up your room.
So you shut the door and you go away and
you magically hope that when you come
back the room will be clean.
But of course the child has no idea in
all likelihood at that age,
or maybe it's two and a half,
something like that,
they don't know what clean up our room
means.
That's like way up here,
man.
It's like you told your child there's
mass every,
be a good person,
you know,
and then you come back in half an hour
and they're no better person than they
were and you get upset.
It's like you can't do that.
You have to say,
you see that teddy bear and you know
that that kid knows how to see a teddy
bear and they know how to pick it up
because you've watched him see a teddy
bear and pick it up and you know that
the child knows the name of the teddy
bear.
It's teddy bear.
And so you point to the teddy bear and
you say,
do you see that teddy bear?
And they go yes.
And you say that's good pat,
pat.
And they get a little kick the DOPA
beans.
So that's happy day for the kid and then
they smile at you.
So you feel pretty good about that too.
And then you say,
you think you could pick up the teddy
bear and they say,
yeah.
And so they go over there and not every
kid by the way,
but they go over there and they pick up
the teddy bear and it's like,
it's a good day for both of you.
And then you say you see that little
space on the shelf cause you know they
know what a shelf is and you know,
they know what is space is.
And you say,
take that teddy bear and put it in the
shelf and they go over there and they
put it in the shelf and then they look
at you and you're smiling.
And so the probability that they'll do
that again is now increased because bull
watching new smile produces a
dopaminergic kick and you've just
strengthened those circuits.
So I would highly recommend that you do
that with your children and with your
partners.
Right?
You watch them like,
like a sneaky person and every time they
do something that you actually want them
to do,
you'd notice and you give them a little
pat on the head.
Yeah.
And then they like you,
that's cool.
But if they don't,
if you don't want them to like you
because you hate them and then you won't
do but,
and you think,
well I don't hate them.
It's like,
Oh yes you do.
You just think about the last month,
man,
there's been 20 times you absolutely
hated them.
And maybe that's the predominant emotion
and that's not so good over time.
So when they do something good,
if you really want to screw things up,
watch like a hawk and wait until they do
something good and then punish them.
That's really fun.
That is,
that really messes with them.
And people do that all the time.
So if you really want to muck things up,
you can even do it more subtly.
You can wait until they do something
good,
especially if they've never done it
before and they're just kind of
tentatively trying it and then you can
ignore them.
That's a really good one.
That's even better than punishing them
because at least when you punish them,
you're paying attention.
If you ignore them.
It's like that's,
that's just perfect.
Also takes hardly any effort on your
part.
So that's an additional plus.
So anyways,
so if you're having a discussion with
someone,
it's like what you're doing with this
kid,
you know?
It's like you say,
maybe you're negotiating about meals.
You don't start with,
you're a bad person.
That's way the hell up here.
You know,
you blow the whole person's Schema right
out from underneath them and you might
as well get divorced,
which is what will happen if you keep
doing that.
Soon you'll roll your eyes at each
other.
That means you're getting divorced by
the way.
So if you ever watch it,
he does.
I'm serious.
There's good empirical data on that.
Once you're at the eye rolling stage,
there's no going back.
So you should intervene way before that.
It's discussed that ai rule,
once you've hit disease carrying rodent
status in your mate's eyes,
there's no common back.
So anyways,
so what you do,
if you want to have a conversation with
someone,
that's a corrective conversation.
As you sort of take a Ph,
Eddie and attitude and the attitude is
go to the highest level of resolution
that you can manage.
So let's say,
and that's what you're doing with the
kid.
It's like clean up your room,
be a good person.
It's like,
no,
they don't know any about anything about
that,
but they do know how to pick up a teddy
bear.
And then maybe you think cleaning up
your room is a hundred things like that.
And so you have to teach the child each
one of those hundred things and then
they learn this is the scheme.
They learn what's the same across all of
those different actions that's clean,
right?
Pick up the teddy bear,
put away the lady goes make your bed.
What those have nothing in common
really.
Like the motor outputs completely
different.
But they fall under the heading of
clean.
But unless you fill the heading of clean
with all the subordinate categories of
the action perception sequences that
make up clean kid can't do it.
And so partly what you're doing by
attending to your child constantly is
noticing where they are in the
construction of this hierarchy and they
start way down here,
right?
And so that's why you play peekaboo for
example.
It's like they can do that and you can,
you know,
you interact with them cause you can
watch you do a little something and if
they respond you got some sense that
you're,
you're at the same level.
And kids in playgrounds do that with
each other right away.
So if you,
if you see two three year olds together,
say they're fairly sophisticated for
three year olds,
what they'll do is they'll start playing
a little primitive game with each other.
Like dog,
like a dog.
You know what a dog does when it wants
to play.
It kind of goes like that.
And that's what kids do and that's what
adults do too.
It's a plague,
it's play invitation.
It's like I'm ready but you're smiling.
It's not like I'm ready.
It's and so you can tell the difference
between a play fight and play and kids
can too.
So it's an invitation to play.
And so if you're interacting with your
little kid,
they got that place circuit man that
thing's in there.
Like when there from birth I think cause
you can play with the kid right from
birth at least something like peekaboo.
And so you're on the same wavelength
fundamentally.
And then you interact with them and you
see if they're following what you're
doing is what I'm doing when I'm
lecturing more or less,
I'm watching you guys and seeing if
we're more or less on the in the same
shared space,
you know,
and we want the space to be expanding.
Cause if it's just staying the same,
well you might as well play whatever you
play on your computer.
It has to be expanding at the same time.
That's optimal.
And so when you're playing with your
kid,
you put them on that developmental edge
where they're undoing and then
rebuilding their little skills.
You know,
you can do that.
Like I had this memory from when I was a
little kid a while back and I remembered
I used to go over to these people's
house with my father and my mom and it
was way up in northern Alberta and these
people were Russian immigrants,
children of Russian immigrants,
and they had a farm house way,
way out in the country,
way out by the way there where the
railroad actually ended.
If you walk north from there,
you'd walk until you hit like southern
Europe without fun running into another
person.
It was way the hell out in the middle of
nowhere and in new ways.
They had a nice house,
like a warm house,
you know,
they had three kids and they were way
older than me,
but it was real fun,
comfortable place to go.
And I used to sit in the living room
with my father and his friend.
I said,
whose name was nick?
And Nick was a really playful guy.
I really liked him.
He was like my surrogate grandfather and
I used to,
I don't think I was more than about
three.
I'd sit there and I tried to hit his
foot with my fist and he would be
talking to my dad,
you know?
And my dad would say,
Jordan,
don't bother nick.
Nick would say,
well he's not really bothering me.
And because dad was checking it out to
see if I was an annoying twerp or if I
was a fun kid,
you know,
cause it's a fine line.
And so I tried to hit his foot and he
would move it and I had this memory
allow back and I thought,
wow,
that was a good memory.
And I thought,
what is going on there?
Exactly.
And I realize,
well he sharpened when he was sharpening
me up,
you know,
it's like I was aiming at something.
You're aiming at something.
If you're pointing your eyes at it,
you're pointing your whole damn soul out
it.
You're aiming at something and you're
trying to get your behaviors and your
conceptions in line and organized so
that you can attain that aim.
That's what people do.
You know,
we throw rocks at things.
We've,
we've,
we fire arrows at things.
We shoot guns at things,
we aim at things.
Our whole body is that platform for
aiming.
And I was trying to aim at his feet and
he'd move his feet,
you know,
but he'd let me hit at what now and
then.
And so let's say you're a rat.
Okay.
Because like I said,
a rat's,
a good model for a person.
Let's say you're a little rat,
a juvenile male,
and you want to play because you wanted
to play and you'll work to play.
And that's how we know you want to play.
If we're experimental psychologists
cause you'll brush,
but button push like mad to get access
to an arena where you can wrestle with
another little rat.
And so rats wrestle just like human
beings and they even pin each other just
like human beings.
And they love that.
And so if you put little rat a in with
little rat B and little rat B is 10%
bigger,
little rat B can stomp the hell out of
little rat a all the time.
So they go out there and have a little
dominance competition and little rat B
is going to win because he's bigger.
So now he's dominant rat.
So then they play and they wrestle and
little rat a loses.
And then next time they both know that
little rat a is the inviter because he's
subordinate.
So he's the one that has to go up to the
big rat and go,
you ready?
And the big rat.
Then we'll wrestle.
However,
if you repeatedly pair them and the big
rat doesn't let the little rat win,
at least 30% of the time,
the little rat won't invite him to play
anymore.
And that was Jaak Panksepp who figured
that out.
And that is mind boggling because it
tells you like the bit,
there's a,
there's an ethical basis for play that's
so deep that the damn rat and their
rats,
right,
not known for their sense of fair play.
The big red has to let the little rat
win 30% of the time or the little rat
will not play anymore.
And even rats know that it's so profound
that discovery like Panksepp discovered
the play circuit in mammals.
That's a big deal.
That's like discovering a whole
continent.
Like that's a big deal.
He should have gotten a Nobel prize for
that.
And to see that that's built in that
sense of fair play,
that's mind boggling.
You know,
cause that's evidence for the biological
instantiation of a complex morality,
fair play.
Even if you can,
when you shouldn't all the time.
Well.
So when I'm trying to hit nick's feet
with my hand,
like I'm really paying attention and
he's moving it pretty well but now and
then I get to nail it and I'm feeling
pretty good about that,
you know?
And he makes a little bit more difficult
all the time so that my aim gets better
and better and I'm building up my motor
coordination.
I'm building up my social skills because
I don't hit too hard and I don't cry
when I Miss Because that just makes you
annoying to play with.
Right.
So I'm learning really complicated
things about how to go about finessing
my aim.
And that's what you're doing with your
kids and what are they aiming at?
Well they aim higher and higher.
So when my son was about two and a half,
we had him start setting the table.
It's,
you don't say,
you know you want to take grandma's fine
China and to go set the table.
It's like no you don't do that.
You say you know what a fork looks like.
He goes,
yeah I see.
If you weren't at the forks are,
well that doesn't work.
Cause the drovers way up here,
right?
So you have to hand him a fork.
You say,
look,
take this fork and go put it on the
table and he's this high,
you know,
so he goes over to the table and he puts
the fork up here,
can't even see what he's doing.
He puts the fork up there and then you
know,
he's reasonably happy with that and you
give them a path and then you go and
give them a really sharp,
not no,
you don't do that.
Don't do that.
You give him a spode and you say,
well go put the spoon beside the fork
and you don't say,
look,
you stupid kid,
you've got to leave enough space between
the fork and the spoon so the plate can
fit there.
Don't you know anything?
You're stupid.
It's like,
well that's right up here,
right?
You're a bad kid.
No,
that's bad.
You don't do that.
You go down here and you say,
well good micro routine adaptation
there,
Chum,
let's try it again.
You know when you build that up and like
man,
you can't extend the kid passed its
point.
His point or her point of exhaustion
because it's got to be a game and a two
year old can probably only do that for,
you can watch them and some are more
persistent than others,
but 10 minutes,
15 minutes,
you're pushing your luck.
You can take a two year old to a
restaurant for about 40 minutes and
expect them to sit and behave.
But after that,
you know,
they're,
they,
they're the will exhausts them.
All right.
Well,
anyways,
that's piaget and his nascent form
fundamentally.
And so if you,
if you remember that diagram and you
think about how that would be built from
the bottom up and how there would be a
stage transition every time those things
are learned,
you kind of got the essential elements
of Piagetian theory.
So we'll see you Thursday.